script idea let's say you've seen
someone or something or an idea comes
into your head and you say I want to
write about that I want to finish 100
pages yeah what's your whole process
from page 1 to done this is gonna sound
terrible
there are things you're supposed to do
as a writer that you should do you
should make outlines make your character
breakdown so all these things that you
like do and make your cards you plot out
your story or a first and second third
I'll do any of that none of it yes
folded sock drawer yes that's the guy
who does it all correctly I don't know
any of it I like to sit and think about
the idea and then I like to think about
the character who that woman or man is
and what they're like and what their
world looks like and then I just start
to think about what the movie might look
like in my head and once I sort of start
seeing the movie itself in my head then
I start writing in I don't know how it's
gonna end necessarily unless it's a
thriller if it's a thriller
I need to know how it's gonna end so I
can know where I gotta go if that makes
sense you know
because you always want to have that
ending that big goal so you think of the
ending first like what would be a cool
hole and then okay now how do I get
there
so I go backward if it's a thrower if
it's not a thriller if it's just a story
about people and life and love or
whatever it is then I don't really think
that much about what's gonna happen I
just sort of think about the people and
where they are and where I want them to
be what the world's like what they enjoy
there's usually a lot of wine involved
because I enjoy some wine and what
happens is I end up writing I think
something that's much more organic and
much more
Here I am a writer and I can't find a
word what is the word organic and what
is it what's what's the word when
something just spontaneous Monday's
organic I end up writing something
that's more organic and spontaneous
because I haven't sort of telegraphed it
and kind of like when you're acting you
know you always hear don't play result
you know because you've read the entire
script so your character is on a journey
so you know what that journey is but the
character doesn't know so you don't want
to play like you know what's coming
because you'll telegraph it to the
audience I find the same thing works for
me as a writer by not knowing everything
when I'm writing I'm discovering it as
I'm writing and it makes the writing
process exciting for me because I'm like
sitting there at the keyboard and I'm
like this is great
you know what's gonna happen next I
don't know I can't wait find out either
you know what I mean it's like it's a
spontaneous thing and then hopefully the
training and and and the laws of
inevitability that I try to keep focused
in my head you know kick in as I'm
writing and when it's done it's it's a
really great it's a really great story
but yeah III I like to look at it as a
living breathing story that's unfolding
as if I'm watching it and that drives me
toward the end because I feel like if I
do all the outline stuff for me if I do
all the outline stuff I've already kind
of done it already so that's like oh I
gotta write at all hated all that I
hurry figured it out so I just like jump
in start writing
you